fit all my mom's calling oh yeah that's
interesting that's interesting hello hey
mom thank you mom
I got your message sorry mom I didn't
text you back but I loved it you know I
read it how's dad his behaviors good is
he pooping on himself no is he pooping
on himself he poops on himself
OOP OOP boneless yeah oh you're the
toilet yeah okay all right so you don't
have to clean up any poo then oh you
used to put your fingers in his butthole
yeah yeah yeah I hated on and he's
talking and everything he's not even
talking oh that's so sad you don't
understand yeah yeah yeah yeah mom Bob
up
she died what is that what is that well
we have a gift from we have a gif from
Jade Kenna peretta with Jake had a
pretty got me a pizza sent you a pizza
thank you oh my god Thank You Jake at a
printer from the pizza I got call me
mama how did she die your mom mom how
does the photo hang up itself it's a
magic phone it's a magic day that's what
these phones is hanging up on it says
I'm at home right now how do you know
the guy was calling you from Las Vegas
in the first place you know the number
it said it on the phone was that a bad
son no I mean as a kid that was that bad
you coped with that I'm sorry for
stealing so much money it's doing
crystal methamphetamine I did pay it
back yeah yeah but it did a lot of
crystal meth and I jacked off in your
bath bathroom everything yeah no but
when you and dad were at work I would
jack off in your path I know I know you
don't want to think about it I know I'm
the best boy now or lately yeah I hope
my parents yeah yeah
you know you saw the guilt from all the
jizz in your bathroom you know ya know
Steve's not here I'm with my girlfriend
and some friends and we're just drinking
some coffee and uh we have a little cake
but you know I like talking to your mom
no okay mom
we got rejected we don't have the money
so uh I'm not gonna rush it but you know
yeah but I have six animals now you know
that right you would take care of the
animals why not the cat you can't
breathe
yeah yeah yeah remember dad used to rage
out to remember those days he's lame now
we used to come into the bedroom naked
with a with toilet paper sticking out of
his ass and feeding us with a Casio
you thought this is he's here a stroke
mom I can't talk
anyway mom I'm on a podcast so I'm gonna
call you later okay love you okay yeah I
know that was a good dad you're a good
mom sorry for jerking off in the
bathroom I love your mom so much I know
mom okay
I'm on a podcast so I gotta go okay I
love you I'll call you I'll call you
I'll call you later I love you mom I
love you so much
if I give it up for Bobby Lee's mom
every one another so we have another
caller and it's like these are schedules
or something it's like someone had the
gift someone give the gift of scheduling
so it's just as was my mom was my mom
scheduled yes bye you know we were all
coordinating it with my mom we just
talked to mom do you anybody in my
family all right yeah you all right okay
what else did you did you give me a gift
well I gotta go to sleep early have a
table read in the morning okay bye okay
that was not notes pointless yes well
Steve prep your mom oh really that's why
my mom called I had to give you have to
give your mom's number to him and then I
had we had Steve prepped by these guys
because I knew if I just called your mom
right away she'd probably be confused so
I had to have Steven well that was a we
that was strange cuz he's never called
me this late and when she called I
thought dad was dying or something I
know but she never calls yeah this not
at this time so in my head it's always
an emergency yeah so on
but it's fine there was a pleasure yeah
thank you for you guys so did extra
stuff today yeah man I feel a little
[Music]